abend urlaub land präsentiert vorkommt
die krise spezialist für die erlaubnis
in norden kontaktpunkt ch
[Applaus]
fünf tage 200 kilometer bis minus 20
grad
mit dem husky gespann quer durch die
wildnis lapplands vier frauen und ein
mann erfüllen sich ihren traum
doch aller anfang ist schwer
sie hatten streit im gespann von armin
kommt es zu einer auseinandersetzung
der junge und kuba ist verletzt und muss
in die box danach beginnt der genuss der
tour
beim nachtessen redet klartext
effizienter werden nicht herum trödeln
die klaren worte zeigen wirkung die
schweizer haben ihre spannung im griff
erschöpft kommt die gruppe am abend auf
dem höchsten punkt der tour an
[Applaus]
jetzt klappt doch silvia hat schmerzen
im knie sechs uhr morgens da kracht's
auf dem alice durch jazz die elfjährige
hündin durfte bei der gruppe im zelt
übernachten
[Musik]
ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
heute liegt die längste tour vor ihnen
über 50 kilometer dazu eine schwierige
abfahrt
die strecke ist selbst für erfahrene
mascher schwierig euro' sorgt sich um
silja wegen ihrer parkinson erkrankung
und dem verletzten knie wie geht es dir
zu ehrlich ich habe besser geschlafen
hatte warm genug
ich glaube das schaffe ich heute so und
die runde müssen einfach sicher
runterkomme und etwas zu riskieren
du sagst es mir einfach der ist direkt
hinterher sag mir wenn du eine pause
braucht wir versuchen den tag zu
genießen
wir müssen uns nicht mehr zurück
wir schauen nach dem mittagessen
diese gilt es darf nicht so weit kommen
dass sie die hunde nicht mehr
kontrollieren kann
wenn sie umsteigen muss auf ein
schneemobil oder ein auto dann werden
wir einfach hier gespannt auftreten das
ist jedenfalls eine möglichkeit
vielleicht machen wir auch einfach
längere großen es wäre schön wenn wir
als gruppe gemeinsam ein ziel ankommen
[Musik]
im team gibt es eine die sich auf die
lange abfahrt richtig freut die
ehemalige bobfahrerin mich schnell aber
gleichzeitig glaubt essen ein fön die
sich im vordergrund das wichtig dass da
nichts passiert
die ganze arbeit gemacht
fc hochstadt martina dagegen hatte
gestern kopf heraus sehr gut schlafen ja
einen hund minister hat gefälligst die
straße wo mich so wird und hatte durch
laufen
und ja heute energie tankt und es kommen
eigentlich kurz ich bin gespannt ist man
den zauber gott also ich muss ehrlich
sagen weil ich spüre vermissten kater
also aber es ist mir klar sie wollen
gestand dass es nicht einfach nur
durchstehen wenn er sich wirklich ein
sport das kann man so sagen die sind so
süß mit mir also das würde ich sofort
ist gepackt
alle machen sich bereit für die abfahrt
barbara stimmt sich auf ihre art ein
[Musik]
das ist es wichtig ist das lob
red silvia das ist eine
sicherheitsbremse eine kette die unter
den kufen durchgeht
so bremst es die ganze zeit auch wenn du
von der bremsplatten abrutscht geht dir
der schlitten nicht ab das hilft viel
besser entspann dich denen deine muskeln
ein bisschen das ist eine kleine hilfe
dass weder der gruppe noch den hunden
etwas passiert auf der langen abfahrt
wenn der fuß von der grenze wünscht oder
sie sogar runterfallen und die kontrolle
über den schlitten verlieren dann wirken
diese ketten unter den kufen wie eine
starke bremse der schlitten wird nicht
in die hunde hinein
so spielt es keine rolle ob sie runter
fahren diese ketten hier braucht dass
niemandem etwas passiert
[Musik]
zwei kilometer abfahrt 200 höhenmeter
steil und kurvig durch bäume und
zwischen verschneiten feldern hindurch
[Musik]
eine abfahrt die auch zu einem
langstreckenrennen gehört dem lappland
quest das zero mit seinen hunden
bestreitet
[Musik]
den schlitten zu kontrollieren ist harte
arbeit
[Musik]
die profis kommen die abenteurer alle
unten an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war eine verrückte abfahrt ich habe
es geschafft er ist vom tag fühlt sich
jetzt wie ein spaziergang an die brems
ketten halfen danke vielmals für deine
tipps mit der gewichtsverlagerung ja
nicht runter gefragt das war kein
einfaches spiel
am anfang sind die werte werden kann
ich find's super rtl aktuell mit kaum
schlechte das ist kurzfristig sowohl
[Musik]
rhetorik sein zeigen und macht so hätte
mehr zeit und unter schindler und haben
sich nicht so emotional stolz damit ist
klar was ist wir brauchen wir finden das
ist auch humus echo ist ein beruf ist
das ist
ich erinnere mich noch letztes jahr beim
rennen lappland quest haben sogar die
profis nachher gesagt dieser hügel hätte
sie geschlaucht und die haben jahrelange
erfahrung zehn punkte für alle hier
genießt den rest des tages gut gemacht
warum sich einfach so das ist auf das
konto des lebens
das schwierigste stück ist geschafft
[Musik]
erst vier tage sind seit dem start der
tour vergangen und aus anfängern sind
fast richtige mutter geworden
[Musik]
sie verschmelzen mit ihren hunden zu
einem thema
[Musik]
sie stören die ruhe und weite ihre
herzen fühlen
mit der freude die sie gesucht haben
[Musik]
vor dem verschneiten sie nochmals ein
augenblick zum genießen die strecke an
diesem tag ist noch lang aber der stress
vom anfang ist gewichen
umfragen belegen wir alle wissen ohne
pause brachte es ist hört dieser moment
kommen vom abschied oder die fcc
vorstellig es manchmal sehe ich wenig
schön und das war seine weg die sich
einem liefer und natürlich angst um ihn
geschehen und das gab dem urban ins feld
starken nur dann spaß live dabei
[Musik]
die route führt über denselben weg den
sie gestern zurückgelegt haben die hunde
kennen ihn
[Musik]
nach zwei stunden fahrt ein stoppsignal
von tour guide juhu davon hatte er der
gruppe nichts verraten
ich passe auf die runde auf und ich mach
das schon legt mir die snacks für die
hunde raus ich habe keine mehr
sie hatten die leute von der gemeinde
passmann die haben von unserem abenteuer
erfahren und haben eine kleine
überraschung bereit
[Musik]
ich schau zu den hunden und schicke die
gruppe hinüber zur alten mühle
ich habe so eine ahnung dass sie da
etwas feines erwartet dass marie ist
eine kleine gemeinde mitten in den
wäldern lapplands mit 31 einwohnern
verteilt auf 8,3 quadratkilometer am
gleichnamigen see
umso größer der stolz darüber den
schweizern ihre sehenswürdigkeit die
alte mühle zu zeigen wo sie essen und
musik vorbereitet haben
ich will
[Musik]
wir haben nur etwas kleines bei euch
noch etwas symbolisches danke vielmals
barbara bittet armin zum tanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die leute aus bass marie haben
stundenlang lokalen lachs geräuchert die
gruppe erlebt die traditionelle
finnische gastfreundschaft familie
vermisst aber nicht aufs korn ihr großes
ziel
das modell ist es ist für mich zum
tankstopp und zur burg schnell drauf und
und das wc
das wissen auch seine frau weiß das ganz
genau dass ich das genieße und das ist
nicht das entscheidende ob es existiert
oder nicht
aber sie erfreut wenn sie bis caritas
roggisch meinte und so sind einfach die
schneehügel mitte zieht wenn irgendwie
was gerade um eine blöde oder hüfte oder
im buch gedruckt und dann chronisch aber
das ist mir einfach so der politiker
erholt instruktionen muss so ausbauen
dass wir einfach spaß wenn wir einfach
muskulären im cranach und plumps und das
problem wieder sehen wir müssen weiter
vielen dank
es war für uns eine sehr schöne
überraschung zwei uhr nachmittags noch
liegen über 30 kilometer in der
dunkelheit vor ihnen
[Musik]
silvia die befürchtet hat nicht mehr
mitzuhalten ist immer noch dabei die
temperaturen liegen bei minus 15 grad
mit über 15 km pro stunde ziehen die
hunde die gruppe durch den wald für sie
gibt es kein halten mehr
dann ein schreckensmoment
beim überqueren einer straße werden die
hunde in der dunkelheit fast von einem
bagger überrollt
alles ist noch einmal gut gegangen
[Applaus]
und armin bekommt an diesem tag noch
einmal die geballte kraft seines
hundegespann zu spielen
ich glaube auch umgekehrt jetzt hat ihn
verrückt ist
vorher war auch ein anstieg bei dem ich
für ein paar minuten festsaß und den
schlitten raus zu lassen
aber dieser hügel ist wirklich stark wir
machen oben sicher eine pause und kann
wieder die ketten run zum bremsen und
wir fahren runter zur hütte
seit über sechs stunden unterwegs vor
ihnen liegt der letzte große aufstieg
der tour
[Musik]
die schlitten sind beladen mit bis zu 40
kg nur gemeinsam schaffen mensch und
hund diese herausforderung
[Musik]
b
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oben angekommen
silvia ist stolz sie hat mit ihrem arzt
gewettet dass sie ihre parkinson
symptome auf der tour weniger spürt es
trägt zur sache machte im happy machen
wenn es auch noch so streng ist das
symptom habe so wenig wie nötig machen
über sich nachdenken warum hätte ich
gerechnet dass wir den hut bitte machen
wieder nach
noch eine abfahrt
ich wünsche mir dass dieser traum nie
aufhört ich finde es okay dass das der
letzte anstieg
ja das verstehe ich aber mir gefällt
einfach alles
die zum träumen und konstruiert dass das
passiert wirklich dankbar
das ist für mich das team klose nahm
sich jetzt voll 45 tage der natur lassen
wir es später mit der natur zurück der
heime sind bin ich wie diese talks dazu
von mir hier nicht modern sind es die
freiheit oder heute stark prägend ich
werde ganz bestimmt sehr oft und ihre
moment oder die tat club tanke und also
versuche die qualität mit der ruhe vor
der stilllegung von moment sie mir sind
oder ich merke ich wünsche mir doch so
für mich dass ich probiere das man im
alltag das nicht der moment genießen
jetzt bin und nicht weiter versuchen die
du siehst auch infos und termine danke
und all die freudigen werde freut wir
gefühl haben wenn sie rennen wenn die
säcke zu das ist für die alles die sind
zumal man die säcke und glaube da ist
[Musik]
die tage alleine mit den hunden in der
wildnis lapplands neigen sich langsam
dem ende zu
[Musik]
gegen 19 uhr erreichen sie ihren letzten
rastplatz am see
[Musik]
alle haben es durchgestanden
die runde und die abenteuer rennen das
hat sie schon ziemlich herausgefordert
das war sich am limit und selbst für
mich nicht einfach
sie mussten bestimmte aus ihrer
komfortzone aus ja ich glaube das hat
gestimmt
zum letzten mal versorgen sie ihre hunde
für die nacht musste sich als vorstand
der mensch mensch mensch tier beziehung
zwischen bezirk und den händen und trug
sie ist bewundere dem uns was sie ihre
energie bewegen die faszination ist so
begeistert denn ist egal wie schwer das
ist der nächste gast
die machen einfach die gerne einfach
straight los ich habe mich definitiv
verliert das kann man wirklich so sagen
und es wird gar nicht am montag ein paar
kurzen gedanken
weil ich wahnsinnig innerhalb von vier
tagen bin ich keine zahl aber so eine
liebe zu rom
und daran ist
aber das ist schön der iranische samt
portmonee
nicht nur sind es die speziell mehr
menschen finden
[Musik]
ein letztes mal aufstehen ein letztes
mal ein spannender runde die ihnen ans
herz gewachsen sind und ihnen das
unvergessliche erlebnis ermöglicht haben
[Musik]
jo hat vertrauen in junge hunde gesetzt
etwa in die einjährige mayday und andere
von denen er nicht wusste wie sie das
abenteuer meistern
[Musik]
sie haben sich viel besser gehalten als
ich erwartete gestern war verrückt aber
sie haben durchgehalten oft keine hunde
einen tag lang eine harte strecke rennen
du siehst erst am nächsten tag zu
übertrieben und bis zu schnell oder zu
weit weg
mädel hat alles gefressen am morgen und
am abend
jetzt sieht sie aus als hätte sie gar
nichts gemacht
das war die richtige entscheidung und
auch das richtige tempo
ich war überrascht dass ich sie nicht in
die kiste nehmen musste
das waren mehr als 50 kilometer heute
einige harte aufstiege es freut mich
wirklich dass meine hunde immer noch so
gut drauf sind haben wir die girls etwas
auf das ist die richtige einstellung
was bedeutet dir deine hunde
das werde ich viel gefragt und die
antwort ist immer noch nicht einfach es
ist ein mix zwischen einem haustier und
da im sport kollegen wie in einem sport
team
manchmal habe ich das gefühl ich bin der
coach sie die athleten oder die kollegen
aber im nachtlager sind sie dann eher
wie tiere für die ich sorge es kommt
darauf an
aber ich würde sie trotzdem nicht
einfach als haustier bezeichnen mit
denen macht man nicht so etwas
verrücktes man wirft ihnen auf dem sofa
ich glaube eigentlich sind sie
teamkollegen oder kommt diese hügel
nicht hoch aber sie brauchen dich auch
für das
dass du für sie so horst jetzt könnt ihr
euch etwas entspannen
[Musik]
st
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für eine kurze zeit aus den
verpflichtungen des alltags ausbrechen
[Musik]
fünf menschen die sich nicht gekannt
haben sind zu einem team geworden
[Musik]
sie mussten lernen sie mussten sich
überwinden
sie mussten kämpfen und sie haben alle
etwas gewonnen zeit
[Musik]
zeit wieder einmal zu spüren wer sie
sind und was sie wollen in der weite und
der ruhe lappland
[Musik]
und so endet dieses abenteuer dort wo es
vor fünf tagen begonnen hat auf der
ranch von jura
[Musik]
mit fünf menschen die ihrem leben ein
neues kapitel hinzugefügt haben
[Musik]
und fremde zu freunden gemacht hat
denn manchmal ist es an der zeit das zu
tun wovon man immer geträumt hat
[Musik]
lappland präsentiert von conti kreise
spezialist für ein langes in morde
kontaktpunkt ch